I asked you to repeat that because I was too busy texting on my phone.
I'm gonna hang up on you and pretend it was an accident.
I'm attempting to sound empathetic because quality assurance is listening.
The only perk of my job is not seeing your face.
Please stop telling me this pointless story.
Just tell me your problem so we can both get on with our day.
I'm saying this with confidence but I have no idea if this information is true.
I'm not sorry you feel that way.
I'm not sorry that happened.
Oh no, I understand.
I just don't care.
This job has made me dead inside.
This job has given me a fear of talking on the phone.
Listen babe, call me hon one more time and I'll burn this place down.
Have a great day.